Your core values
are an essential part to finding a great partner,
and a lot of people don't realize that.
That could be why they only find
unfulfilling relationships.
For example,
I was talking to a client about how I could tell
from talking to her
that humility and fairness were part of her core values.
Yet all of her exes were cocky guys
who would be the type of person to skimp
out on tipping the waiter.
Because she was so
focused on finding men who had flashy jobs
or were sweeper off her feet,
she completely overlooked the fact that they had wildly
different values.
After that, we helped her start looking for humble guys
who would spend them time doing something
like volunteering on the weekends,
a huge shift for her.
So here are a couple of tips that you can do
to tell if someone shares your values.
My first tip is to ask questions on 1/1 date
to give you insight into a person's values.
Like what's a perfect day like to you?
Or who do you spend most of your time with and why?
And second, or to do activities
that are in alignment with your values.
Suggest volunteering one day
or go to a dive bar instead of a trendy one
and see how they hang.
The important part of this is to notice their reaction
when you do these things.
Start with those tips
and start to notice how your views around
What you're looking for when dating changes